ottawa police service made its first
arrests ahead of the canada day-long
weekend as officers gear up for what
could be a busy few days in the capitol
police say an officer was choked which
led to four people being arrested at the
national war memorial thursday that was
following the end of james tops walk
across canada top a canadian armed
forces vet was charged in february after
speaking out against covet 19 vaccine
mandates we
have freedom here but it is being slowly
siphoned away but
we're going to do something about it
earlier this week ottawa's mayor
welcomed people to the city to
participate in canada day celebrations
despite several protests set to take
place one of those protests in front of
the supreme court building not far from
the main stage where official ceremonies
will take place
there are security checkpoints in front
of several celebration sites and ottawa
police service has brought in hundreds
of officers to help patrol the streets
that's in anticipation of hundreds of
thousands coming to the capitol kyle
benning
global news